you are not on Twitter you're not on
Instagram you are not a knowledgeable
guide saying when it comes to the web
super knowledgeable okay yeah which I
which I admire cuz I try not to do a lot
of that myself yeah I like uh like a I'm
like a Luddite right
yeah you know I'm like but a few steps
away from that like I'm a drag-and-drop
kind of guy
I don't know shorthand commands you know
what I mean I don't like command
whatever to get the thing like I just
like take my mouse and like drag it over
and my friends are generally embarrassed
they're like just like control V paste
it you know no same way easy I'm going
up to edit I'm going to scroll down to
copy okay and then I'm going to
highlight it and then I'm gonna drag it
over everyone's like oh yeah what I mean
yeah that's the kind of guy so I can
relate I don't know how to do any of
that stuff either and I have an 11 year
old son who's just horrified because he
literally can take the thing apart and
put it back together again what I find
ironic is that you have a lot of fans
that are very active on the Internet and
they're always posting things and
there's this whole series called Jake
doing things are you aware of this is
call my life yeah they're very unusual I
think you should take a look at these
there's a first one right here it's Jake
Gyllenhaal amazed by the snow I don't
even know what that's from no no someone
was sprinkling cocaine you'd be amazed
too that would be yeah I would be amazed
and delighted what's the next one I hope
we have another one here Jake
Gyllenhaal's emo phase okay
very strange what's moving on here
somebody yeah Jake laughing at his
sandwich why is that what right
damages are hilarious sandwiches are
really funny I think it's the fact that
you're alone that's Billy what's the
last one Jake Gyllenhaal and a high
school boy band called is this true yeah
were you in a band called holeshot yeah
the guy on the left is like hanging his
head in shame knowing that in 20 years
we were just gonna be on a talk show
right is just afraid he's gonna get hit
by this yeah yeah yeah were you guys
good
you